- We're here in McDonald's
and we're ordering some Shamrock Shakes.
- And it's St. Patty's day.
(hip hop music)
♫ Let's go
- We got 'em.
- I've never had one.
I've never even heard of one.
Mmm,
it tastes like a mint
chocolate chip ice cream shake.
- It tastes like a Junior Mint.
- Mmm,
mmmm.
- It's like the melty part of
mint chocolate chip ice cream,
like the soupy part.
That's the best thing I've
ever had in my goddamned life.
- It's minty.
I don't love drinking mint.
I'd rather have just a vanilla shake.
- It's not as bad as
I thought it would be.
But,
yeah I do like it.
- It's like if you
had those York Peppermints,
shredded the chocolate off,
and then mixed it up.
I think that's exactly what it tastes like
and I don't hate it.
I love it, actually.
- Not for me.
- It's like drinking gum.
- I am offended.
I am personally offended by everyone here.
(hip hop music)